und jetzt das heute journal guten abend
es herrscht wochenendruhe so ein
bisschen hinter den kulissen bereiten
sich bund und bundesländer darauf vor
nächste woche die pandemie regeln von
grund auf neu zu schreiben dann sollen
länder nur noch dort bestimmen dürfen wo
sieben tage ins tänzen unter 100 liegen
sind die drei tage über 100 greifen dann
bundeseinheitliche regeln
das sind dann keine kollegialen
verabredungen der ministerpräsidenten in
vertrauter runde mehr sondern dann ist
das ein bundesgesetz da liegen noch
viele teufel in den details und das wird
ab morgen klarer aber heute kommt das
schon einmal weitgehend ohne deutsches
corona thema aus die afg veranstaltet
den dresden wieder normal statt digital
ein parteitag der die partei geschmeidig
und einig machen soll für den wahlkampf
sie scheut den streit inzwischen so sehr
das noch nicht mal spitzenkandidaten
gewählt wurden der vorsitzende molten
will erst mal ein ganz glattes profil
benjamin schikowski bis dort eine halle
und fast 600 delegierte mitten in corona
zeiten versucht die afd normalität auf
dem podium tragen alle masken und in den
hinteren reihen teilweise ohne muss man
der polizei schon mal einer test zeigen
um drinbleiben zu dürfen raus aus den
streitigkeiten und rheine die einheit
das möchten zumindest die bundessprecher
die nach den letzten landtagswahlen wohl
verstanden haben
wer gewinnen will braucht einigkeit
schluss mit dem lagerdenken schluss mit
den scheren und schranken im kopf
jetzt ist schluss damit es reicht
freunde nehmen wir diesen dresdner
parteitag als signal geschlossen in
diese wahlkämpfe zu ziehen
holen wir uns in diesen wahlen unser
land zurück unser land so wie wir und
viele millionen menschen es kennen
und wieder haben wollen deutschland aber
normal
dankeschön die partei folgt der heutigen
einheitlichkeit lehnt den abwahlantrag
gegen parteichef leuten ab und auch den
versuch einiger landesverbände schon
heute spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl zu benennen das macht
jetzt wie von leuten geplant eine basis
befragung gefällt hier vielen aber nicht
allen
die stimmung an der basis und ich weiß
dass viele über den kurs von heute sehr
verärgert sind
jörg michael ist ein bundesvorsitzende
die partei ein augenscheinlich nicht
integrieren kann und nicht integrieren
will sondern der leider spalterisch
tätig ist und uns schadet nach gut drei
stunden personaldebatte beginnt dann das
wofür man eigentlich hier
zusammengekommen ist das programm für
die bundestagswahl
wie würde denn die afg zum beispiel
corona bekämpfen deutschland würde so
aussehen dass wir auf jeden fall
deutlich besser aus der krise
hervorgehen würden wären diese gesamte
sage ich jetzt mal geschlossenheit
politik menschen daran zu hindern ihre
berufe auszuüben schädigt die deutsche
wirtschaft steht durch den einzelhandel
und den klimawandel will man sogar
positiv begegnen sie wissen dass wir sie
eher skeptisch sind es hat mir noch
niemand erklären können wie bei zwei
prozent kohlendioxid-ausstoß deutschland
das klima verändern kann
nach heftiger diskussion stimmt die afg
am abend überraschender weise und gegen
den willen des vorstandes noch wie für
den austritt aus der europäischen union
und so endet dieser erste tag des
parteitags doch wieder irgendwie in
alter afg normalität im streit
nicole dresden sollte ganz anders laufen
als die selbstzerfleischung der afg auf
dem letzten parteitag november in kalkar
wie gut ist das so insgesamt gelaufen
na ja man hat es ja gerade zum ende des
beitrages auch schon gesehen man hat
hier einen großen drang zum frieden der
beruht aber nicht
das hat man ja auch jetzt gerade gesehen
eher bröckelt ja auch schon wieder und
er beruht eben auch nicht darauf dass
man sich inhaltlich hier angenähert
hätte sondern auch kuren pragmatismus
es gab den parteitag in kalkar
vergangenen winter da hat parteichef
jörg neunten seine eigenen leute
teilweise so massiv kritisiert dass
selbst für afg verhältnisse der folgende
streit erbittert war es gab
wahlschlappen in baden-württemberg und
rheinland-pfalz mitte märz und es gibt
immer noch die drohende beobachtung der
gesamtpartei durch den verfassungsschutz
der einzige grund dafür dass man sich
hier so zusammenraufen will ist sind die
bevorstehenden wahlen ist es purer
nackter pragmatismus und so antwortete
heute auch alexander gauland
fraktionschef auf die frage woher jetzt
diese friedfertigkeit rühre
naja wir wollen wahlen gewinnen aber wie
gesagt ein so oberflächlicher
kosmetischer friede der kann gar nicht
lange halten wird er wenigstens halten
bis zur wahl
das könnte gut sein denn wir haben ja
gerade im beitrag auch schon böcke
gehört landesvorsitzender in thüringen
und vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem ist eingestuft das ist der
größte widersacher von jörg nolte der
für die sogenannten gemäßigten in der
partei steht jörg neunten ist weiterhin
heftig umstritten und als ich heute dann
wieder gefragt habe wie traurig er
darüber ist dass ein antrag auf die
abwahl von leuten es nicht mal auf die
tagesordnung geschafft hat er sagte er
könne ja in seiner brust schlügen zwei
herzen
einerseits sei es natürlich wichtig
geschlossen in ein superwahljahr zu
gehen andererseits sei ja eigentlich
ziemlich entspannt denn im november
höchstwahrscheinlich sei der nächste
bundesparteitag und da werde man höcke
abwählen
bis dahin hat man also noch zeit im
september wird im bundestag gewählt und
danach wird abgerechnet
das ist auch eine art frieden dankeschön
nicole der tag heute ist der hundertste
nach dem exit gleichzeitig der 23
jahrestag des karfreitagsabkommens das
den bürgerkrieg in nordirland beendete
und die beiden themen sind auf
teuflische weise verbunden
experten haben auch in unseren sendungen
immer wieder gewarnt dass das kleine
stück eu-außengrenze dass die eu
republik irland vom britischen
nordirland trend alte wunden wieder
aufreißen und erneut zum bluten bringen
könnte damit die grenze die inseln nicht
so schmerzhaft zerreißt wurde sie de
facto in die irische see hinaus
geschoben das erregt jetzt jede wie um
jeden preis weiter zu great britain
gehören wollen
bilder wie man nie wiedersehen wollte
kommen jetzt nach nordirland zurück
berichtet diana zimmer wieder brannten
fahrzeuge in belfast wer geglaubt hatte
der tod von prinz philip werden die
protestantischen jugendlichen innehalten
lassen sah sich getäuscht
seit zwölf nächten machen sie ihrer wut
gewaltsam luft
der von brandsätze und steine zündeten
busse an und attackieren
polizeifahrzeuge insgesamt 88 beamte
wurden verletzt seit jahren hat die
hauptstadt nordirlands solche szenen
nicht gesehen hauptursache für das
aufflammen dieses alten konfliktes ist
der bressert um den handel über die
grenze zwischen irland und nordirland
nicht zu hemmen sieht der handelsvertrag
zwischen eu und großbritannien vor
das waren kontrollen auf der irischen
see durchgeführt werden
obwohl der britische premier immer
wieder gesagt hatte genau das werde
nicht passieren
meiner ansicht nach geht es im kern um
den betrug durch boris johnson er hatte
versprochen dass es keine grenze in der
irischen see geben wird eine de facto
grenze zwischen nordirland und
großbritannien während die grenze
nordirland zur republik irland offen
gehalten wird das so glauben die
unionisten sei nur der erste schritt zu
der von ihnen gefürchteten vereinigung
nordirlands mit irland unsere jungen
leute fühlen sich in ihrer identität
angegriffen und sehen ihre zukunft
bedroht
sie fragen sich wird es ein vereinigtes
irland leben und wie werden wir dann
behandelt werden die fühlen sich british
sie wollen teil des königreichs bleiben
die frustration über einen schier
endlosen cupid lockdown heitz die wut
der jugendlichen zusätzlich an eine neue
generation erlebt nun die gewalt die das
land jahrzehntelang beherrscht hat dass
dabei schon sehr junge kinder mitmischen
empört die justiz ministerin hieß es
gibt probleme die angegangen werden
müssen aber nichts davon entschuldigt so
weit und den zwölfjährigen die da
mitmachen geht es natürlich nicht darum
wie der exit umgesetzt wird oder dass
ihnen die kugel regel nicht gefallen
sondern hier ist das problem die
gemeinschaft um sie herum die sie als
kanonenfutter für ihre eigenen
schlachten benutzt
die schlachten zwischen protestantischen
unionisten und katholischen
nationalisten gehörten der vergangenheit
an
als vor 23 jahren das
karfreitagsabkommen geschlossen wurde
begann der prozess der heilung doch
durch den dreck sind alte wunden
zwischen den gemeinschaften wieder
aufgerissen das london und brüssel
momentan kaum miteinander reden macht
alles nur schlimmer
in belfast befürchten sie einen heißen
sommer nachrichten und zurück nach
deutschland
in der union mehren sich forderungen die
frage der kanzlerkandidatur rasch zu
klären
cdu-parteichef laschet und csu chefs
sollten sich innerhalb der nächsten
woche auf einen vorschlag einigen
erklärt cdu-vize bouffier in der
frankfurter allgemeinen sonntagszeitung
andernfalls würden die partei präsidien
einen weg zur entscheidung weisen auch
unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus dringt
auf eine klärung innerhalb von zwei
wochen gegenüber der funke mediengruppe
fordert er keine hängepartie bis
pfingsten die aktuellen corona zahlen
sind wegen der feiertage weiterhin nur
bedingt belastbar
es zeichnet sich aber ein anstieg auf
bereits hohem niveau das rkw meldet 24
1097 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
das sind knapp 6000 mehr als am
vergangenen samstag 246 menschen starben
in verbindung mit 19
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
steigt auf 120,6 im jahr sind polizei
und armee erneut brutal gegen
demonstranten vorgegangen
dabei sollen binnen zwei tagen laut
bürgerrechtlern mehr als 80 menschen
getötet worden sein
die militärregierung verhängte zudem 19
todesstrafen trotz der gewalt gingen im
süden mehr nach maß die proteste gegen
die militärjunta weiter die hatte anfang
februar die zivile regierung gestürzt
und die macht übernommen
immer wieder nehmen wir uns in der
redaktion vor die pandemie als das
weltweite geschehen zu zeigen dass sie
ist das scheitert oft an dem was uns von
tag zu tag dann doch wieder näher liegt
heute aber nicht die bevölkerungsreichen
länder südostasiens teilen viele sorgen
und ängste die auch wir haben und dazu
kommen dann noch die eigenen in diesen
ländern gehen gerade die geburtenzahlen
nach oben leider nicht weil mann und
frau im lockdown neue freude an
gemeinsamkeit entdecken sondern weil in
einer wirtschaft im lockdown der zugang
fehlt zu mitteln der familienplanung die
dringend gebraucht werden
deshalb kann normen odenthals bericht
aus indonesien jetzt nicht einfach ein
heiterer film über familienglück sein
damen und herren und amba mariana ins
mikrofon haltet abstand wascht euch die
hände bleibt gesund und vor allem
benutzt verhütungsmittel verschiebt ihre
schwangerschaft auf die zeit nach der
pandemie
ihr dürft heiraten ihr dürft sex haben
aber seid vernünftig und werdet nicht
schwanger es ist also eine ziemlich
klare ansage mit der sie indonesiens
städte und dörfer beschallen schwanger
werden jetzt keine gute idee sagt amber
von der stadtverwaltung semra diese
pandemie stellt die familien vor riesige
herausforderungen
wir haben eine wirtschaftskrise keinen
tourismus schlechte geschäfte die männer
verlieren ihre jobs es sind die frauen
die das geld verwalten und für sie wird
es eben immer schwieriger eine große
familie mit kindern zu ernähren
kinder machen reich kinder machen arm
was für ein dilemma arbeitslose männer
haben zeit und nicht nur lust das kommt
dazu am ball verteilt heute kostenlos
verhütungsmittel der staat will nun ganz
bewusst gegensteuern denn experten
erwarten dass die geburtenzahlen in der
pandemie um etwa 10 prozent zulegen
[Musik]
wenn uns die behörden sagen dass wir
wegen der pandemie die hände waschen
sollen okay aber wenn sie sagen werdet
nicht schwanger das finde ich schon
komisch ich finde die aktion gut
auch die durchsagen ich habe das alles
gar nicht gewusst aber jetzt sagen sie
uns das ja ganz offiziell
da sollten wir uns daran halten
aufklärung mit am ball
zur wahrheit gehört dass die pandemie
auch für lieferengpässe bei
verhütungsmitteln gesorgt hat die sind
überwunden doch für manche kommt das zu
spät
herr li na ist wieder schwanger alles
läuft gut sagt die ärztin weiß aber dass
ihre patientin nicht glücklich ist
die schwangerschaft ist ungewollt ein
unfall sozusagen sie bekommt jetzt ihr
viertes kind und für die familie heißt
das wirtschaftlich wird schwierig
beschwerlich ist es schon jetzt für herr
li na die trotzdem jeden tag ihren
kleinen imbiss stand öffnet denn die
familie braucht die einnahmen mehr denn
je bislang kam sie gerade so über die
runden aber jetzt noch ein hungriger
mund mehr
ich mache mir sorgen als sich die
nachricht von der schwangerschaft bekam
habe ich geweint
denn unser geschäft läuft auch nicht
mehr gut wegen der pandemie
mein mann hat nur noch gelegenheitsjobs
es ist schwer diese pandemie hat viele
risiken und nebenwirkungen in den donne
siehen gehört ein baby-boom dazu
generation corona
prinz philip soll in einer woche am 17
april auf schloss windsor beigesetzt
werden ganz großbritannien trauert die
zeitungen widmen sich umfangreich den
ehemann der queen der im alter von 99
jahren gestorben ist
ihm zu ehren wurden in den vier
hauptstädten des königreichs in london
edinburgh cardiff und belfast kanonen
salven abgefeuert ebenso wie von
kriegsschiffen der royal navy die
gewinnzahlen vom motto lauten ohne
gewähr
469 15 27 45 superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text das april wetter bleibt zunächst
wechselhaft und frisch morgen ist es von
den alpen bis zur oder freundlich sonst
bedeckt und regnerisch an den küsten
später auch in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen teils mit schnee 4 grad
im nordwesten bis 21 grad im osten und
südosten am montag im südosten viel
regen und schnee bei 3 bis 10 grad ab
dienstag beruhigt sich das wetter und
wird auch wieder etwas milder und alles
vom sport jetzt gleich im sportstudio
wir wünschen ihnen einen schönen sonntag
und hoffen dass wir uns dann am abend
hier sehen ist
[Musik]